[Music]
I did it looks like you're there in the
face with our but you can probably see
the shadow cast by the Rocky Mountains
from the Sun at the right angle like
that earth is way more smooth than the
moon only focusing on the mountain range
yeah so it's actually fake from orbit
you can see clouds cast but shadows cast
by clouds on the ocean that's all what
is the best way we can get first step
will be to go to the website triple-a
org or calm that comes the other
Association right perfect yep triple-a
dork
check the calendar we show the upcoming
events we have a big event coming up in
October first in Central Park ship
meadow
we call it a star fest that's the
biggest of the meadows in Central Park
yes fairly far south
you entered through 6767
okay and there will be many Forks with
our telescopes sharing the sky with you
and you can so you don't even have to
have your own telescope you can have
professional amateur astronomers show
you their telescope through our
telescope many telescopes there are
different sizes different technologies
for different purposes and you may
realize you only like to look at the
moon you find the other stuff not
interesting or you only like to see
globular clusters or different thing so
then you know what else got to get and
we have many telescope we have so many
volunteers that very generously granted
time with their telescope so any member
and anybody from the public you don't
even have to be a member can go and take
a look through a telescope and see what
they like and then
[Music]
you